all right another 968 whoa that was a
quick move right here out of the gates
whenever I see two bishops on the GH
files or a B files i think they don't
need to move in order to be developed
it's just the ponds that need to move in
front of them and they're good where
they're at I think this is actually a
good start and I'm probably going to
mimic it you know I don't know that
there's a better spot now one thing I
won't be doing is playing my night here
because this guy is going to be very
upset with me and so too is this guy
look at the domino effect this pond
can't move then that Bishop can't move
let's not do that to my pieces so in
other words if my Knights not going to
play here where should it play here now
I don't obstruct this pond here maybe or
maybe here first and then night here a
lot of ideas and I don't have the
answers to all of them oh man what do
you do what does this guy do woke word
what about this night hmm
well
here here this bishops not too happy oh
it's tough to come up with a plan in
these 960 games of course I could just
move quick and play recklessly but I'm
trying to come up with a pretty decent
plan one that I would maybe try and do
in a game where I had powers to be
thinking about stuff I'm trying to find
something decent here esox and then get
my bishop out in this direction let me
try that support my center point right
and well let's get my night out of the
corner you stupid there I guess the
ladies are off coming off here okay
that's interesting i can't Castle
kingside now can I okay my light square
Bishop would one day like to play I
could castle let me do that I look
certain good spots and I could support
this pond with this move mine i could
play here I think I want to go I don't
know pompous just a single square and
then a single square and then get my
bishop out in this direction but the
door slammed on it with f4 I think I
know how to get my nights working but
it's my bishops I'm having trouble with
right now what are they what do they do
hmm time push
I can't go to squares let me just go one
let's see
Bishop to e6 and pawn to g6 and
no what I don't know what else here ok
now the night hmm i'd really like to not
have to push here because then one of
the nights could eventually sit here i
would like to have the lightscribe
bishops exchange and sink and night on
that e4 square how can i make that
happen I just can't be easy I actually I
have an idea involves a night c4 move
followed by Bishop here even though my
pawns are doubled maybe I could be
making use of this square and I need to
move this pond like real soon like maybe
I should have done that first yeah I
should have done this move it's more to
the point I think
um well that night is pinned oh there's
just going to be castle next I better
get going my dark square Bishop wants to
play one day let's go dark square Bishop
and this night is going to be pretty
annoying i think if night here i don't
want to push because i'm chasing the way
to ask where it wants to go to so I'm
being very cautious of these e 4 & e 5
squares now that can throw that night in
a pin man tight game here I'm definitely
not taking that punt no way that night
is going to be beautiful on f5 on e is a
very good chess 960 player I think
that's all we play and these are always
really good games very cool man alright
let's take here the pond captured away
from the center so it's hitting my night
what is it no longer doing it's now
watching over this square so maybe I
could get here with my night I'm also
threatening Knight takes pawn I do best
to just let these guys sit I really
don't want to push because my bishop is
well I guess maybe can come out in this
direction um what else Bishop f7 whoa
what is happening my opponent is lashing
out is there a good reason for this if
there is i'm not seeing it i could take
the rook or take the night first is the
move order going to matter
my opponent might fall for something
sneaky back Reggie issues with the
bishop check if the brook ends up
leaving the back rank I think we might
be seeing this right now tricky stuff to
come if rook takes pawn don't you do it
don't do it it's leading to me or the
loss of material the loss of material
check rook lock Bishop deflection
whenever you have your opponent in a
position where their pieces are tied
down to the defense of other pieces look
for the tactic of deflection and that is
what this is looking to do right now
deflect the King away from the defense
of the rook there's no good solution
there's a bishop block but that's
actually leading to mate still ok but
before that point came about what a good
game as usual let's back up here and see
about things huh I like that move in the
center I don't like this move though I
know you have two pawns in the center I
have one just focusing on the four
squares your pond has more possibilities
than my own pond maybe you could push
forward maybe you could capture retain
that option retain the tension in the
center that's one suggestion and I think
actually my main suggestion yeah let me
just point out one thing and that is
retain that tension what can you do
instead of that pond push how about this
f4 that's better or maybe consider push
push gaining space I like this though to
be honest if there's a move to go with
I'd like the f4 move retain this tension
because then you keep me guessing you're
going to push you're going to close it
up you're going to gain some space going
to be cramping to my queen side or this
section of the board or are you going to
capture later keep me guessing the long
you keep me guessing the more
it becomes for me to deploy the rest of
my pieces okay let's close out of that
retain the tension is my main thing to
pull away from that one